jobs water hope what impresses me is
that you're 17 years old
and you're graduating high school and
this is your first job
passing out fitzwater yeah what made you
to want to do this yeah from Flint so I
didn't want to help out people that I
you know I hope well fun I want to be
making sure that you know I can help out
those wider distribution visa work
hurting pretty significantly I have some
friends that you know losing hair rashes
you know have the affective before that
we were struggling with you know the
poverty and you know strong people they
want get better just dropped up on water
here actually gonna go inside and talk
to this family to see how things have
been for them so I see you guys have
pile of the bottles of water and we got
some on a basement steps because every
time they come we try to get as many as
became because they
Wow so what do you use it for everything
bathe cook and whatever else to fix the
babies models and whatever else
everything we don't use the fossil
watering they say it's supposed to be a
little bit better not to each was that
nope do you think that
no that's why we trying to gang up
enough money to get out of here you want
to leave Flint yeah you want to go
nowhere close it's a real crisis
unfortunately it's not exaggerated it's
real if you knock on these people's
doors and they're so excited to see
water it's an essential need it makes no
sense that somebody's it's so excited
for an essential need you know what I'm
saying so it's it's something that
everyone has to do it's not it's not
volunteering it's a necessity that we
all asked American citizens need to put
in the work to help our communities out
so since you're graduating this June
where do you hope to do next year at
this time hopefully you're deep in said
get into the grief of Nursing because
like I said I like to help people with I
believe this is a step and a stepping
stone onto my way of helping people do
you want to get out of Flint to study
yeah I want to get out of Flint so I can
you know it's the other things and you
know I could say I help people around
the world and then you know still you
know get enough money hopefully I can be
some type of getting in there to where I
could think you know me as a dollar if
that's the city well
you